[موسيقى]
مسجد وكنيسة وأول معبد يهودي في أبو ظبي،
ثلاثة
أماكن عبادة مبهرة ومذهلة من الناحية المعمارية
في قلب دولة
الإمارات العربية المتحدة،
مشروع يهدف إلى تعزيز
الحوار والتفاهم بين الأديان
جلست مع رئيس
الجامعة الإبراهيمية  منزل عائلة محمد
المبارك والمهندس المعماري المشهور عالميًا السير
ديفيد أجاي
محمد ماذا يعني لدولة الإمارات العربية المتحدة،
لديك دولة الإمارات العربية المتحدة اليوم أكثر من 200
جنسية تسمى دولة الإمارات العربية المتحدة،
لذلك نحن بحاجة للتأكد من أن كل هذه
الجنسيات لديها الراحة لتسمية
هذا المكان  الصفحة الرئيسية لماذا تم اختيار داود
كمهندس معماري لقد تم اختياره بسبب
ما بداخله هنا أنت تعرف
إنسانيته وجهة نظره الإنسانية
ولإنجاز مشروع مثل هذا
وفهم جوهر الإسلام
وجوهر المسيحية وجوهر
اليهودية كان يحتاج إلى  فرد
يمكنه أن يفتح قلبه لذلك، هل
يمكنك أن تأخذني خلال المشروع
كما تطور في عملي. أنا
مهتم دائمًا بالنظر حقًا إلى
جذور الأشياء
وتاريخها ولكن هذا سمح لنا بالعودة تقريبًا
إلى  بحث للعودة إلى
نقطة الصفر حول ما يجمع الناس
معًا، وما الذي يجعل إيمانهم هو ما
يشكل ثقافتهم،
وكان ذلك بمثابة إثراء كبير
للاستوديو لفريقي، وأنا أغوص
في جوهر الإسلام،
وجوهر المسيحية، وجوهر
اليهودية
في حياته.  عظيم
نيس
وفهم حقيقي لما
تعنيه هذه الأشياء في الطريقة التي
يتم بها بناء البشر على مدى
آلاف السنين، استلهم بيت العائلة الإبراهيمية
من مبادئ
الأخوة الإنسانية وثيقة وقعها البابا
خلال زيارته هنا في عام 2019. هذه
الوثيقة  تم التوقيع عليها من قبل البابا فرانسيس من قبل
الإمام الأكبر في ظل وطني صاحب
السمو الرئيس وهي
وثيقة للسلام العالمي، إنها وثيقة للالتقاء، إنها
وثيقة
تذكرنا بما يفترض أن تفعله حياة البشر
فهم بعضهم البعض
وقبول بعضهم البعض  البعض الآخر ونتطلع
إلى مستقبل أكثر إشراقًا بكثير،
فالمشي في كل منزل هو
تجربة عميقة يدمج السير ديفيد هذه
العناصر في كل منزل لإنشاء
مساحات روحية وملهمة هائلة،
لذا فإن ما لديك هو في الأساس
تفسير لقوة كلمة
الله في  الإسلام هو في الحقيقة فكرة
النظام الذي يوفر مساحة متساوية
للمصلين لمواجهة الكعبة، بحيث يكون
لديك أربعة أعمدة
تحمل السقف، فهي مربعة،
لذا لديك تسع قباب تأتي
من هذه الأعمدة الأربعة وهي
الدوران  من المربع إلى القبة
الذي يخلق هذا النوع غير العادي
من التوتر في المبنى ثم
التأطير بين أعمدة
الفطر الذي ينشر
الضوء بشكل أساسي من جميع الاتجاهات من حولك
ويخلق هذا الضوء المبرقش الجميل
الذي ستراه  في جميع
المشاريع هو أن الأمر يتعلق دائمًا
بتصفية الضوء وتقسيم الضوء
في كل مشروع أفعل ذلك بطريقة ما ولكن
في القناع، يحيطك الضوء
حتى تصل إلى صمت
ورزانة مواجهة مكة
[موسيقى]
[  الموسيقى]
أم
الكنيس موجه نحو
القدس، لذلك هذا هو التكريس
للمعبد وكل معبد من
المعابد له تكريسه عندما تمشي
عبر الأبواب ثم تجد
نفسك في هذه الغرفة التي تتسم بالهدوء الكئيب والهدوء الخافت
قليلاً وإضاءة خافتة  ذلك
لأن الكنيس مستوحى من
فكرة عيد العرش والإقامة
والبرية وعلاقتك بالله،
لذا فأنا أعدك لأخذك من
العالم الحضري إلى هذه البيئة
التي تدور حول ثروتك الروحية،
لذا فأنت في  عيد العرش
وهذا هو الحجم الذي يبلغ 30 مترًا
وأنت في هذه الجماعة مع
البيما في المركز وكوة واحدة
لذلك في هذا المعبد كوة واحدة وهذا
توقيت رائع جدًا لأن ضوء
منتصف النهار يقبل الحاخام في
المركز
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
مكان يوجد فيه رواة قصص ليحملوا
قصة سبب أهمية
الأجانب
[موسيقى]
تربط الحديقة المرتفعة جميع المباني
وتخلق إحساسًا بالهدوء الراسخ،
لا شيء هنا يدور حول جلب الأشياء
بعيدًا عن القارة، الأشياء
التي  تجد في القارة أننا قمنا
بتحويلها إلى حديقة مركزة بحيث تكون
الأعشاب وأشجار الفاكهة والكركديه والياسمين
وتزدهر وتتفتح
بطرق مختلفة بحيث يكون لدينا
موسمية في هذه الحديقة ولكننا
اعتقدنا حقًا أن هذه كانت فرصة
لجلب  جميع الأنواع التي يمكن أن نضع
أيدينا عليها في هذه الحديقة ونجعلها
بمثابة احتفال بهذه المنطقة
[موسيقى]
جولة موجهة نحو شروق الشمس في
هذا المشروع، الكنيسة أعتقد أن الأمر
يتعلق بالإيمان، لذا فإن هذه
الأعمدة الهيكلية الضخمة تنظر إلى فجأة
تتوقف فوق رأسك عندما تدخل
وتقول بإيمان ادخل،
إذًا نحن الآن في الكنيسة
وأنت في هذه اللحظة التي كنت
أعمل فيها على فكرة
روح كلمة الله، كما تعلم
أنني صنعتها في الأخشاب لأن
إنه أيضًا ينعكس بطريقة ما على فكرة
السفينة
جيدًا استخدام الخشب وهذا
شيء انعكس على
جسد عملك نعم قبل هذا نعم
بالتأكيد أنا مفتون بالجو
الذي تم إنشاؤه  مع الخشب
وكيف يعمل داخل
المساحات التي نخلق فيها الحركة، فما
يحدث لهذا هو أن
ضوء النهار يتخلل في
أوقات معينة من اليوم كنوع من
الشظايا الصغيرة ثم يتم
دعمها بالضوء الاصطناعي ويخلق
هذا الجو الذي تشعرون فيه جميعًا
معًا في جماعة جسد
هذه السفينة التي هي
الكنيسة
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
بينما نجلس هنا اليوم، هل
يمكنك التفكير في
مشروع المعالجة وكيف يتناسب مع
حياتك  لقد
كانت الرحلة مذهلة
وأعتقد أنها غيرتنا جميعًا، وكما
تعلمون، ما زلت لا أصدق أن هذه
الفكرة التي كانت في رأسي أصبحت الآن مساحة
نجلس فيها ونتحدث عنها،
إنها
تجربة متواضعة جدًا  أن نكون قادرين على خلق مساحة
وإنشاء
دور عبادة أجنبية على أساس مشترك
يعزز الشعور بالإيمان والتفاهم